.
>> UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE MAKING
FURTHER GAINS IN THE DONETSK
REGION.
TO YOUR SOCIAL MEDIA SHOWS
NATIONAL PLAYED, IN THE
HOMETOWN, NEAR LIMA.
PRO RUSSIAN FORCES STILL
CONTROL THE POCKETS ARE IN THAT
AREA.
THE CRANES ARE CLOSING IN ON
THE MOTHERS.
CNN IS THE FIRST TV CREW WITH
ACCESS TO THE AREA AROUND LIMON,
WHERE THERE'S FIGHTING HAS LET
LITTLE STANDING.
HERE IS --
>> HIDDEN BUT ON STOP
HEADED UNSTOPPABLE, YOU CAN
HAVE BRAG MUCH ABOUT ITS MARCH
SOUTH, FROM KHARKIV, CHOICE OF
THE PRICE OF DONETSK, BUT EVERY
WITH TOP OR TREELINE SUGGEST
THEY'VE BEEN TOO BUSY
ADVANCING.
DAY-BY-DAY, REDUCING HOW MUCH
OF OCCUPIED UKRAINE, MOSCOW IS
ABOUT TO FORCEFULLY DECLARE
RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
WITH THE ULTIMATE GOAL,
ENCIRCLING THE VITAL RAILWAY
TOWN OF LIAM ON, CLOSE, NO
QUARTER GIVEN, ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE FOREST TO THE
MONASTERY TOWN OF SPOTTED
HORSE.
THE DRIVE TO THIS POINT,
PROBABLY THE MOST PRESSING
HOURS ON THIS ROAD.
ALSO MONTHS OF THIS WAR, LAYING
BARE, THE OTHER FEROCITY OF THE
FIGHTING AND ALSO TO THE SPEED
OF UKRAINE'S ADVANCE TO THIS
TOWN.
WHICH ITSELF, IS SHOCKING,
EIGHT YEARS AGO, AT THE START
OF THE CONFLICT, I LIVED ON OFF
HERE, FOR SIX MONTHS, AND JUST
LEARNED TO APPRECIATE IT
NORMALITY, IT'S PEACE, A MIDDLE
OF PINES HERE.
AND THAT'S JUST GONE.
>> IT IS THE MOST FRAGILE WHO
REMAINED WHEN RUSSIA MOVED IN.
ANNA IS ONE OF NINE PEOPLE LEFT
IN HER BLOCK.
SHE ALMOST DIDN'T MAKE IT.
HERE [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
[INTERPRETER]
, THE SCARIEST IS WHEN THE
RUSSIANS WERE IN MY COURTYARD,
I WAS IN THE DOORWAY AND TRYING
TO HOLD THE STEEL DOOR SHUT.
BUT A SOLDIER PULLED OUT THE
DOOR, SO I JUMPED DOWN AND FELL
IN THE BASEMENT.
HE TORE OPEN THE DOOR, SHOT HAS
GONE TO THE DARKNESS, AND
MISSED ME.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> SOME SIX REVIVAL IN THEIR
GOT HERE WHO'S MANAGED IT LOOKS
DOWN ON THE MESS.
LUKA, ASK ME IF THEY WILL COME
BACK.
THE RUSSIANS, THEY MADE SUCH A
MESS OF THEIR NEW POST OFFICE,
SHE SAYS.
ON HER SHIRT, A LOCK OF HAIR,
FROM HER LOCAL BELOVED PRIEST,
KILLED BY SHELLING IN JUNE.
>> I TESTED AS A PROTECTIVE EYE
MILLET, SHE, SAYS TELL ME,
COULD I LEAVE HERE NOW?
>> EVEN THE CARCASS OF HAIR,
STILL ROCKED BY FALLING.
BUT THE CHURCH BELLS FINALLY
RUN AGAIN, TWO DAYS AGO, THEY
BROUGHT HER TO TEARS RUN.
>> IT'S, WANG AND I HEARD, IT
SHE SAYS, AND I LISTENED, AND
IT GOT LOUDER.
THEY ARE NOW OUT OF THE, CHURCH
BASEMENT, WHERE THEY HEDGE FROM
THE BOMBS AND STILL TRIED TO
LIVE.
>> CHASING ITS CODE DOWN, HERE
YOU CAN FEEL THAT SEVEN MONTHS
UNDERGROUND.
ACTRESS TONIGHT SHOW THEIR
FACES, THEY APPLY DOWN HERE IS
THEIR PRIVATE TRAGEDY ONE SAYS,
HER DISABLED SON WAS INJURED
AND YELLING, AND TAKEN TO
HOSPITAL, SHE TELLS ME.
SHE LOST ON HIM ALIVE BUT THAT
IS ALL SHE KNOWS DOWN HERE.
THERE IS A LITTLE SALVATION
HERE.
ONLY RUINED TURNING TO RUST.
THERE IS NO LETUP AND UKRAINE'S
ADVANCES.
OR OF MOSCOW'S IMMINENT
ANNEXATION.
THE ABSURD CLAIM THAT THIS LAND
IS NOW ACTUALLY RUSSIAN
TERRITORY.
THE LAND HERE TESTIMONY TO HOW
THE COLLISION BETWEEN TH